Have you taken the red pill ?
That means
not taking the blue pill
and waking up to the fact
that what you've been told
is often wrong.
You take the blue pill.
The phrase comes from the movie The Matrix.
Believe whatever you want to believe.
You take the red pill,
you stay in Wonderland
and I show you how deep the rabbit-hole goes.
That moment in The Matrix,
Morpheus is offering him simply the truth.
Candace Owens says she took the red pill
and now her YouTube channel
offers red pills
to millions of others.
People don't care
to watch CNN
anymore.
People are paying attention to YouTubers okay?
My second video
went trending worldwide with 80 million views.
80 million?
80 million.
It's obviously
the media's fault.
In that video,
she mocked the media
for finding racism
everywhere.
The persistence of racism in America.
The surge of hate,
the online racism.
CNN was trying to sell to me,
as a black person,
that the KKK was alive and well.
That was ridiculous.
Oh my God, Charlottesville.
White supremacy is alive and well.
So I made a video just essentially making fun
of the narrative.
How ridiculous that I should be
scared to go outside
because the KKK is alive and well.
Another police shooting
of a black teen.
She also complains that the media
imply
the biggest threat to young blacks
is the police.
Police officer charged with murder caught on camera
shooting an unarmed black man.
Fact number 1.
Approximately 93 percent
of black homicide victims
are killed
by other black people.
Police violence
is a real threat.
No, it is not
and I will not allow you to say that either.
It is not a real threat, okay?
Some innocent people have been
tortured by police.
That's absolutely right.
Some innocent people
have also been struck by lightning.
16 unarmed black men were
killed by police officers in 2016.
If you are watching CNN,
you would have thought
it was happening every single day,
okay that's a problem.
16 represents point
zero zero zero zero four percent
of the black community.
And yet there were riots,
and there were protests,
and Black Lives Matter
has actually resulted in more black deaths
across the country
because police officers don't want to answer the call.
It's not popular in the black community
to say such things
or
to say that you are conservative.
Owens jokes in this video that
it's easier to tell your parents you're gay.
Mom, Dad,
I'm a lesbian.
I like girls.
Oh sweetheart,
we always knew.
Oh, thank you guys.
Oh, also I think I might be a conservative.
I don't understand.
Guys it's totally fine.
it's okay,
I just, you know
think a little more conservatively.
But sweetheart,
you're black.
Mom, I'm still black.
I simply think that we should maybe
put the economical future of this
country ahead of the social issues,
that is all.
Sweetie,
can you please just be gay?
It's more difficult to say to someone
I'm a conservative.
Candace says the big issue facing blacks
is not racism or police shootings, it's
dependence on government
that began 50 years ago with
Lyndon Johnson's Great Society programs.
They incentivized mothers, right,
to not to marry their fathers.
That's why single motherhood is up.
The government would give you more
if you didn't marry him.
We are fully reliant on the government.
My entire family is on welfare,
save a couple of people
and what it does is
they essentially offer you some money
and then they say wherever you work, okay
you don't make enough
so we're gonna give you this much money
on top of that.
So they do what?
They say, oh I don't want to make more
because the government is already giving me
five hundred that I don't want to lose and...
And your entire family's on welfare?
Yeah pretty much.
My entire family's on welfare.
And they still like you?
Yeah they love me.
I'm great, right?
Oh celebrities,
now I rarely think about Russia.
Fear absolutely dominates black people.
Like hamsters on a wheel,
run, run, run, run, run, run.
What the government has done successfully
is made people insecure.
People don't think they can do anything
without the government.
We've got the government regulating nail salons,
eyebrow salons.
The government has extended an overreach into
every single arena of our lives.
The time is now
for black minds to be unleashed.
People don't understand is how many black people are
so excited about what I'm doing,
how many black people see the opportunity,
and how many black people are very aware
that they have been duped by the left.
She calls that
taking the red pill.
Who else has taken the red pill?
Brandon Tatum,
he's got a pretty large following
Your success in life
is dependent upon you.
There's CJ Pearson,
who says he's the left's youngest problem.
Black lives,
they do matter.
So do white lives, though.
And I think why
some of these black conservatives
have not been successful in the past
is because they care too much
about what people thought.
We're doing it differently.
We are talking a lot of trash.
We are very sassy.
The African-American community is
suffering from a poor memory.
We want people to know
you can feel free to call me an Uncle Tom,
you can feel free to call me an Auntie Tom
it does not affect me.
Do you want to know why?
Because I actually read the book
and Uncle Tom was the hero.